bring the offspring yeah coming back
with the offspring mix it up a little
bit hey by really yeah you mean you
don't like the offspring I mean I I like
that album smash but it's not from smash
no I like this song this is like yeah
this is like a good pump up song right
Thank You same to do what I don't notice
yeah drown yourself throw a couple
bricks in your pockets and jump in the
river Mike doesn't like to come back to
anything that's not 20 years old wait
wait era of off-screen and that's pretty
fly for a white guy moment that was like
that was like the peak of of it like
saying like it's cool to be white yeah
that was also thinking that went away
I think 1930 [ __ ] I think the offspring
I think they started is oh we're gonna
be a cool band and then they were like
what if we kind of were just like a
parody band yeah you know what if yeah
smash wasn't a match was amazing it's um
one of my favorite albums from when I
was a kid but then everything else after
that was like what if we just did comedy
records you know I mean yeah it's like
there's a song like my friend's got a
girlfriend and yeah hate that [ __ ] why
don't you find a job yeah it's pretty
bad yeah terrible but everything on
smash was great
yes noodles like a genius too there yeah
what's he like yeah yeah yeah and
what's-his-face the the lead singer he
made like that kind of money fine and in
finance is his name right Dexter Holland
Holland yeah they still playing or no
yeah I think they still tour because
they did have a resurgence they what you
know what they tapped into something
they were like well in the mid 90s
people are making music that's good so
let's make good music and then the late
90s came and they were like oh music
sucks now we should make music that
sucks and everybody liked it there was
big at the time look at this tracklist
for smash bad habit got to get away
ah come out and play self esteem are
they popular songs those songs yeah I
mean their songs are incredible yeah
play one that's popular for a second my
favorite self esteem is really good
important stuff sorry but come out and
play with so big - I was huge that was
probably the biggest
I think this one's uh oh yeah I remember
this I've heard this yeah
yeah it's so of the time though isn't it
[Music]
please come out and play I bet I bet you
know come out and play to be a white
dude with dreadlocks and and pull that
off is yeah good for him yeah you could
though in that I ain't ninety four
ninety nine though even then it was that
was a short window yeah of course yeah
it's okay I never loved it but it's fine
so what arrow is that song that Mike was
playing from I hate that you know I hate
it yeah it sounds like [ __ ] yeah to me
it sounds like the [ __ ] something
it's the Monster Mash yeah we're like
The Addams Family just I hate it it
feels like it like something out of it
terror like pulp fiction that part I
always hated yeah Sam that's a 2008 cut
you played offspring from 2008 the [ __ ]
are you doing that's gotta be the
craziest decision I've ever heard of my
life that's from their album rise and
fall rage and grace who would even know
that there were offspring songs from
2008 oh it's a craziest thing I've ever
heard
it actually was number one for 11 weeks
on the rock chart making it their
longest run yeah but the rock chart in
2008 was like nothing it was it was a
tumbleweed
Daniels was number two yeah you know for
my money doesn't get any better than the
Macarena
do you remember that fine and it has
great great replay value I enjoy that
remember Yankees game maybe alright
instead of the seventh-inning stretch
everyone's doing the Macarena Macarena
was good I would never do it I'll just
sing heyo well Sam Morelle is here Sam
is gonna be in Atlanta Washington Tampa
Pittsburgh Sam Morelle Antonio I forgot
to add that one
San Antonio as well you me at all the
dates and his podcasts and everything
over at Sam Morril comm speaking of
bands wait I have a question before you
please before I forget yes
is this legit I want to make sure it's
legit before I promote I guess it was a
lady Di's son is he uh that's actually
okay I couldn't find an email from him
or something I couldn't find it I was
like I didn't actually I knew it was a
little dr. Steve tweeted it and using
contact with her son okay firm lady died
she was a it's her Saiga she has
dementia and her son is doing a GoFundMe
for her she was a friend of the show for
a long time yeah character on the show
for a long time really give us a lot of
fun moments okay it's good
so yeah I'm yeah I mean will retweet
that from our account yeah um no you're
talking about bands Nickelback's
streams and downloads went through the
roof because of that Trump tweet yeah
except they made them Warner Brothers
made Trump made Twitter's stupid take it
off why is that stupid that's even by me
keep the publicity going they got well I
guess it does keep it going yeah yeah
they got the day of publicity yeah yeah
and then they were like another day of
publicity because Warner Brothers just
like yeah that's copyrighted take it off
yeah think it's Trump tweeted out a meme
making fun of the Biden family with the
song photographs playing background but
yeah now I guess everybody went I can't
I can't imagine the people would go oh I
forgot about that song I gotta hear
that's right photograph by Nickelback
yeah that what's more if you wanted to
hear Nickelback head up coyote ugly
playing all that crap what's that like
early 90s I don't know early
two-thousands not even early to back
look I know they're considered not great
by a lot of people would are they as bad
as people say they are is it just like a
hip reference to say that they saw
because that's definitely a hip
reference to say they suck so say
awesome name for a band true they do
they do suck do they like their it's
just nondescript are they all so uncool
they're very uncool they're Canadian
that hurts
yeah I think mom shows Rush
you know you have a rush is cool well so
yeah that once you consider it uncool as
a rocket it's all [ __ ] done they're
in the category of Creed
damn Creed yeah
Creed got to a point where it was almost
ironic like they were so uncool if you
started to like him because it was funny
Nickelback it's like that's not a funny
man don't hate that whole era of rock I
don't know define odd are not J won't go
and calm down back it's more like blink
182 yeah yeah I'd say Nickelback
probably sucks on the level of I mean in
my opinion maroon 5 but I know now a lot
of people like sorry with you there you
would Ruth I'm like really suck he's a
great songwriter yeah I do love Adam
Levine songwriting you do you like his
body too handsome guy and you like all
this song I like five songs sure you
like that song sugar
Troy is like dancing like the Joker with
is like spine out of whack who's uh yeah
considered horrible bands now I mean
maroon 5 is it bad as horrible as it
gets there hated but he played the
[ __ ] Superbowl how do these feel is
that just for women is that just you
like men are gonna watch the game let's
book let's book some horrible [ __ ]
different demo that's what sometimes
they go with a male Donald I think a lot
of times now they want a different demo
so you don't down to something else
during halftime that was cool and they
had Tom Petty at the halftime I like
when they had like a real band yeah
McCartney's done it yeah mom moms like
maroon 5 for sure you're right that's
but they do but people gonna watch the
Superbowl anyway you don't the book of
[ __ ] they might turn it off during
halftime so they want something that
will keep like you know again moms or
whatever glued to the television yeah
and not just turn it all it's just it's
basically formulaic but rock that's a
good way to put it yeah formulaic but
Riley fives not even rock
no it's formulaic but music is meters
we're sipping the hater-aide it's
formulaic drivel yeah
much like pitbull pitbull schools worse
than people I enjoy pitbull hey same see
so Nickelback the bed who Nickelback's
bed maroon 5's bad pimples horrendous
you think this is good sugar you like
sugar I like this song it's a good song
that's what you're sitting here saying
as a musician you're gonna sit here and
tell me this is a good song I wish I
could write a song that sells like this
one that's not I'm not asking about
sales so you're just looking to sell
records it's a strong look you're a
sellout you don't need a song to be good
you just want it to sell you don't think
any musician could have that song I'd
like to give myself a strong hook right
now it's horrible horrible I can give
you a list of any Nickelback songs worse
than this no what is it no it's not it's
really bad and it's catchy and that's my
least favorite [ __ ] which is why it's
formulaic [ __ ] you have any idea how
hard it is to write a strong hook that
gets stuck in people I'm sure it's crazy
it's difficult you know I bet yeah you
know what misbehaving is stuck in my
head all the time and that's just a
goofy song they wrote for a comedy show
yeah I tried writing a song and it just
wasn't catchy how did it go the hook was
I love you more than soup nobody bought
it no I don't like I get okay like you
get credit for writing something that
was catchy I'm not talking about it
doesn't make it good is it hit though a
big deal if it gets if it's infectious
and gets stuck in your head and it
translates so to brain tumors don't you
think pop do anything most popular music
is terrible like most of the most of the
top there's a good popular music and
there's a bad popular for sure but don't
you think the bulk of it is pretty
terrible I mean look at my music case
has been Kirino
do you like Sean DePaul I love Sean Paul
yeah I'm a big venom guy too Sean Paul
man that [ __ ] I hate that [ __ ] so
much I had a temperature
I'd in college who was getting hazed by
his frat and the entire he would just
get woken up all night with we be
burning guns I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna
break your [ __ ] face and high Syria
and Jim isn't just being like he's not
being cute I've like you like this
unlike play like glue by Sean Paul I've
heard that like glue is actually a
pretty good stuff oh I think it's
[ __ ] brutal in here like I don't
really care what people say I don't
really care what dem gaan do have a
slight accent I don't mind it this was
like one of the early Sean Paul hits
this is one of his big breakout hits
[Music]
that's okay I'm not mad at this song I
don't I go with it
does this comes on hold on is this on
the record after yardie bone I think
this is after a song I like nobody knows
what the album tracks are 88 million
hits starts I've seriously been on
airplanes with Jim where I look over and
without him even noticing that I'm
looking Sean Paul is playing on his
phone he listens to it recreationally
like glue is on what is it what you guys
yeah what are you listening I know you
love Ozzie what else do you listen Sean
Paul Sabbath yeah kiss Ramon's a lot
yeah yeah Johnny Cash Sean likes a good
cover
I do the album is on dirty right no that
dirty rock you spray is uh which is a
tournament of the worst bands oh man the
worst bands like the the sweet 16 and
the Elite Eight like who do you think is
worse maroon 5 or Smash Mouth I like
Smash Mouth dude
you like smash I do when I have girls
over we're making out I say Alexa play
smash man
whatever doesn't get a laugh by the way
everybody it hits sitting there at home
under with dumb Amazon's in their houses
have smashmouth plain yeah Alexa place
play can't get enough of you baby yeah
it's right what about that Smash Mouth
was able to get infectious hooks people
that play the beginning of can't get
enough you baby and tell me that it
doesn't make you want to get up and do
it before you do that
Alexa dial nine-one-one tell me this is
again all the badges wet in the room
when you hear this hook so you know no
Troy by your definition Smash Mouth is
great no I appreciate it their ability
to have hit songs I mean tell me you
hear this and you're not the all your
ladies aren't in the mood right five
years later we're still talking that's
right so they've turned a corner they
are now cool they get into social causes
on Twitter that's cornball stance I like
it when he goes like eat [ __ ] people
think Smash Mouth III feel like you guys
aren't understanding the lyrics here
this is literally the sound of the late
90s this song here yeah the late ducks
can't hardly wait is the movie dude this
is the song yeah this is the sound of me
driving home from Pennsylvania three
o'clock in the morning record scratch
that's cool yeah dude don't you forget
it yeah I'm down Smash Mouth don't
forget it I'm down smash meow it's truly
terrible song nowhere near as bad as
more than five memorize my so much
better than you in five are you kidding
me I like it yes I think after the show
today we need to go back to the office
and we need to start putting together a
list of the tournament that we're gonna
put together to find out who is the
worst band in the world yeah Alexa play
sugar that's my new go-to you ladies
like this sugar sugar I mean it might be
sugar might be the worst band [ __ ] song
by the worst band Alexa go to pornhub
well Alexis a speaker I don't have it
dude it's I didn't think I would like it
but mark Normand turn me I mean Comedy
Central sent us these dumb Alexis I was
about to throw it out and mark Normand
it's like dude you got to use it it's
great I got one for Christmas a couple
years ago it never got out of the bottom
line away I'm not having one of those
speakers in my go I know they're
speculating in 10 years we I think the
time frame might be a little off it
won't have phones anymore because you'll
just say things these you're gonna look
at phones the way we look at stuff in
the 1950s like you know and looking like
what the [ __ ] was that these will
eventually go away phones yes and then
with what's know it's gonna be like just
automatic like Alexa that we're not
gonna have something that we care about
did your brain connected to you right
yeah I guess maybe her not in 10 years
but yeah dude I want some [ __ ]
computerized girlfriend that's [ __ ] a
pocket [ __ ] that like vibes with the
computers your dick wouldn't it be funny
if like iPhones got replaced by pocket
[ __ ] with Alexa [ __ ] ringing new
iPhones and wives have been replaced
yeah it's really like it's given us
probably some sort of cancer and are in
our leg you know I was just being being
in our pocket all day they're gonna know
it they're gonna go and they're gonna be
like we're gonna take the tumor out and
also install like an Alexei in your
thigh
Oh God scary man did you a pocket [ __ ]
growing up I didn't I never did my
friend's dad did and I and we [ __ ] it
once gangbanged his dad's pocket [ __ ]
dude there's so much like kid come in
there
hey his dad didn't know what he was
[ __ ] we took turns on that [ __ ] ho
did you all finish in it - no no we had
respect okay good for you that's nice we
drew the line at finishing in the same
pocket push I'm not about the cream pie
my dad's pocket [ __ ] wouldn't it be
awful if you had a pocket [ __ ] you find
you call your dad was drinking out of it
those national lampoon's een you like
dad yeah totally yeah Chevy Chase would
absolutely Clark Griswald know did you
have a pocket [ __ ] Jim um it's a boy no
I've used one I didn't like I didn't
like I like my hand yeah the flashlights
the new thing I've never used one of
those either no I know I'm old school
man yeah I got one here I took it home
used it one time threw it right in the
trash yeah yeah cuz it's just you know
pump and dump Brad in New Jersey what's
up Brad Sammy bran muffins is a longtime
listener living in New Jersey but I'm
originally Canadian little offended by
your remarks about Nickelback sucks
because they're Canadian
no Nickelback sucks and the fact that
they're Canadian makes them suck more
the good stuff that comes out of Canada
is still good but if you suck and you're
Canadian it definitely makes you suck
more huh yeah listen the reason why I
Nickelback sucks is because Chad Kroeger
ended up marrying what's that chicks
name by the way don't ever don't ever be
Smerch ever Levine's name in my presence
no no no he married Emma Levine he did
that's why you know no Avril Lavigne is
so much better than Nickelback oh stop
it you can have your maroon 5 in your
chicken tenders and dude you take the
[Laughter]
Mireles well please because he's a
fantastic comedian I'm a huge fan thanks
man we have a mutual we have a mutual
friend who's got an amazing band if
we're going to talk about music
100 pounds check them out you know is
the great Colin Smith sure yeah check
out hundred pounds that's some good [ __ ]
enough for this Nickelback nonsense okay
thank you really good
yeah but it's not as fun to talk about
good bands no I want to talk about
shitty bands cartridge bands the only
good bands I'll talk about the Smash
Mouth he loves Smash Mouth so what do
you hate what do I hate [ __ ]
I don't know it's it's got it yeah I
really don't like that the what I've
heard of Nickelback I like I mean I
don't know if I hate stuff cuz I'll
listen to [ __ ] ironically you know like
does Nickelback mate that song crazy
[ __ ]
oh no that's Buckcherry bad band
Buckcherry that's on this that's a
[ __ ] bad band Buckcherry yeah I like
those guys are the band oh yeah
I mean it's a little cheesy if you're
outside I'm not I'm not offended by it
like if you're out of there somewhere
and you hear this song come on you're
not like oh this is [ __ ] terribly
just like okay I just kind of thought
nothing I'm hearing it I hate I gotta I
gotta think about that who's really bad
when you get this hold of a song this is
probably you know 20 years old or
something isn't it no I definitely run
to this song take a bag this sounds
pretty good you just start getting
nostalgic it's like yeah I mean I don't
see that she's a crazy [ __ ] though but
she looks great yeah I don't have that
visceral you know what band does not
hold up like I couldn't bring up a band
and be like oh this is actually okay
what puddle of mud I never I never knew
their music really I was into him when
they were like out when I was I was
probably coming out of high school going
into college it's just like mm but they
do not and this is Fred Durst discovered
this forget these guys Fred Durst is the
purveyor of art the song is bad this is
nineties right it's like 99 mm I like a
lot of cheesy 90s music though yeah I
like like a generation I hear like
Everclear pop on him I gotta like it I
like pop punk rock bands take Everclear
I like real Punk bass like Everclear and
Dishwalla what else I'm missing what
else yeah like I like like I look at my
Spotify you what do i hmm
yeah like when this came out I was like
[ __ ] yeah there's a great song [ __ ]
hates yeah I can really do that yeah
fight with my girlfriend
or you know your mother there was
something it was like an anthem you know
I hate the [ __ ] white guy t-shirt
derby look so much I hate the soul patch
the little like just I'm only gonna have
a soul patch well I thought you were
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] Azure I got a bad
band oh let's see it I want to saliva I
don't know that I don't know them Oh
five good one saliva saliva is a good
that's a good call Troy Oh
click-click-boom
live is tough so I was like commercial
hard rock that's just that guy the
singer just looks like a [ __ ]
jerk-off I don't know dude I kind of
want to buy a Dodge Ram right now
exactly you know this song you could
picture it like I don't love this like
fighters coming out to it or but it's so
yeah there it has a purpose it's so
generic though it's like I'm a fighter
came after this I'd be like that fighter
just he's got no originality a new way
whatsoever they are rockin you can't
deny it it's so generic I always judge a
baseball player so hard by what they
would saw and they come out - yeah
because you get to choose any song right
and when you and when you choose a
cheesy ass like if it's like a country
song I'm like all right he's like kind
of like a southern guy's and whatever
but if it's like saliva check he
probably just a boring guy totally
you're just a cheeseball it's well I
would be bummed when a player I like
came out to something [ __ ] generic
yeah I agree with Eric in Seattle let's
go to I know you don't like him what's
up Eric I mean I liked it 1 or 2 of the
songs
what's up guys hey yes yeah we're
actually I like under the bridge and one
good album there might be the worst most
successful whoa maybe they're like the
worst good band but aren't they also
people always say that that's like the
band that you see live and you're like
holy [ __ ] because they take the rocks
out though oh by the way when you're
going to see them live you like the band
so you're going to see them that's a
very bad source I'm saying I feel like
they convert people a lot like say you
bring a friend or something they're like
oh [ __ ] they are amazing they're one of
those I hear what about loved their
cover of love rollercoaster underrated
sound Trey it's a great soundtrack yeah
way Tommy's got a song on it yeah man I
don't know it he was imported to America
Rob Zombie animated his scene for that
movie the acid scene
[ __ ] fun movie campus this is the
best chili peppers the Dave Navarro
years yeah I like the other version from
Boogie Nights Boogie Nights is one of
the best soundtracks ever I'm crazy
there's another version of this right
there's a cover
yeah there's a cover this is the Chili
Peppers I can't criticize the song I
taught online this is fun man she's
peppers have a couple okay songs you
know I like the Chili Peppers Mother's
Milk was g-man in Charlotte he's
absolutely right okay let's go to g-man
I don't know I think you got its fanbase
what's up g-man I think you know they
had a bit of time I don't know them
peter-puffer
maybe a race rap group Sam it was a
comedy rap trio do you have anything I
think we've heard it uh yeah I disagree
David in Atlanta you crazy that's good
Dave what's that buddy
yeah man Five Finger Death Watch is by
far the shittiest band of all time out
great if I figure death pots are great
that is a funny thing to say though if
Mountain Dew was a band they'd be
fighting those guys are great [ __ ]
under and over it American capitalists
those guys are really like all be like
whoa b.o.b it's cool I don't I don't
know them I mean I know who they rob I
don't know I'm not definitely with it
they're like Jim they have like some
Sabbath II kind of riffs under and over
it you don't like come on sir put that
on Five Finger Death Punch yeah I like
those guys you know what while you're
looking for that Brian in philadelphia
brings up an excellent point what's up
Brian hey Sam it's toys all over Adam
Levine's dick is that song sugar yeah
it's written by four other [ __ ] hit
songwriter pretty well yeah that's true
like it's so hard to get a hit single
it's like yeah because all these bands
like hire the same three people the
right
all of the hits I mean if you look at
Black Caviar songs there's four people
sometimes on those on our songs you know
what some [ __ ] pisses me off what's
up that could someone call me maybe
why that's a great hit so does that
great pop song it just bugs me it was
the song in the summer like three or
four year and part more than a pipe like
five years ago I just met you and this
is crazy here's my number call me maybe
I like it when you say it I do like a
Lou Reed version yeah this song is like
it was the song kettle my song in the
summer this is a summary song this was
the little nas acts of its time yeah I
want to be at the beach just pinching my
fat yeah Carly Rae Jepsen was I mean you
know lil nas I guess it's like I don't
hope that many songs so it's like cuz
even if it's bad I'm kind of laughing
but this one kind of I heard so much to
just start to bug it was everywhere I'm
from so nas X had old old town road
that's the end of little Naza that's it
Miley Rae Jepsen had this song that's
the end of Carly Rae what's his name -
did blurred lines I guess Robin oh yeah
yeah the state pipe that was fine well
for engagin at first though
yeah however now he gets to be a judge
on the biggest television show in the
country which is the masked singer it's
a big show it's huge
really huge what a dumb idea so stupid
people a [ __ ] dumb it'll be a grand
yet they're all Klansmen David Duke
[Laughter]
I hate to say David Duke did a damn good
cover blurred lines good were you gonna
say Travis I know who the current
Nickelback is so imagine dragons dragons
does universally suck what do they do
you know you've heard five of their
songs and you probably think it's the
same song that's like a punch line
imagine dragon has become a punch line
yeah their name is annoying
what's another band that people you said
you watch it you watch sports so I'm
sure you've heard you know that whatever
it takes song yeah yeah this is pretty
annoying
you're already annoyed it feels like
it's got annoying
anthem type feel to it too it's just
like they're all made for like the
playoffs all their songs are made told
yeah I find this this is literally a fox
commercial yeah like a slow-motion Mike
Trout swing in a bad this is a baseball
commercial yeah it doesn't bother me
this song I don't care how many views
this does it can still suck it can suck
to you but it's still word right no no
we're not Matt we're not arguing mass
appeal were driving our personal taste
sucks I don't mind this maroon 5 has
billions who's talking about maroon 5
sugar to you making my point one of
their songs five is the shittiest band
currently performing out here I'm gonna
sell I'm not working us out dude I'm
gonna if I get a woman back in my place
I'm gonna start smooching say Alexa play
a little [ __ ] radioactive did I get
some imagine dragons on alright have to
I have twenty-one bands on Erlich oh you
like imagine dragons you know what
Travis you might need to add another one
Chris in New Jersey
got it already good what's up Chris I
disagree with this dragon yes somebody
like people like Troy like imagine I
disagree I just know that Troy's trying
to stay young so whatever has hits on
YouTube that's my favorite I don't know
I was I'm taken by surprise this is nice
cool he's a sellout you're a [ __ ]
sellout she's a total sellout
he's a total
if I need to hear thunder one more time
what's thunder it's another imagine
dragon song hold over one second Chris I
promise I'm gonna get back to you Jam
Thunder because we got we got to try
that matchbox 20 stuff - that was
[ __ ] annoying thunder is a horrendous
really it is oh this is right up Troy's
alley it's so bad look at the hits Troy
you can't deny it billion from jumping
in those this sounds like the [ __ ]
Santa and the Moses it was that song and
the gun oh oh yeah definitely sounds
like m-i-a m-i-a yeah I don't like songs
you can picture being like the warm-up
song for like a high-intensity interval
training class this kind of bugs me yeah
I don't love this song the other one I
liked
Troy figures out if he likes something
or not by YouTube hits I'll be nice how
much money that's worth its price a lot
yeah it's worth a lot of money and all
you have to do is suck as fast the 40
year old ladies if I suck right exactly
right right uh hang on I don't want to
steal his thunder let's go to Chris in
New Jersey what's up bud hey first off
this singer from imagine dragons plays a
giant bass drum in the middle of the
stage when they perform at Sony they are
like that exactly but you're literally
going around why don't you ask your mom
if I suck your mom likes me
what's that started I said Jimmy there's
no way that you like that I've been
following you for too long you you
silently writhing at the douchiness I
like the one song with the second one we
played I did not be like radioactive I
was fine you look up a live video and
you'll instantly hate me okay
Travie dog doctor GERD he said mine
matchbox 20 I'll tell you who I don't
like Radiohead
really I know idlest doesn't if they are
awful not even close
I mean I find them
unlistenable just for karma police alone
ecom's great no I think they I don't
like literally anything they do it's
just noise they're probably one of my
top five bands they're awful I would
agree with what Troy said but okay
computer is enough to keep them off the
list the Benz was great masterpieces
Pablo honey how about little biscuit
they were pretty bad Rowlett biscuit is
my favorite band dude i I was I was
working with a comic if you're not down
with the biscuit I know if you come back
here soon I I was working with a comic a
couple weeks ago and he would come out
to let someone like like a chainsaw oh I
remember it was in Sacramento uh yeah it
was yeah it was one of things I'm like
well give him the benefit of the doubt
he did picked it and then two shows
later he was still coming out to him I
go this was his choice yeah it is
sounds like the coolest comic ever yeah
oh you believe it with a fat lip jokes
I'll use this [ __ ] ready I'm
sorry I'm gonna break stuff and point
you they're funny bones there's two
bands I'm not gonna let you come in here
and insult limp Biskit and some forty
one other than that do you you were
nostalgic from the 90s I'm 41 is like
the most 90s band get Ron he's the man
he's the bloke stuff is garbage but I
like his uh kid rock is like a [ __ ]
just created these are just a celebrity
though he's not a real like what play
player could rock songs he's the boy's
God do you really like the country stuff
is okay his rap stuff is corny what
about rock rap stuff it's like rap metal
though or something isn't it course it
is it's the best only God knows why it's
[ __ ] awesome that song Bob with the
bars awesome - cowboy is awesome hockey
is awesome play cocky Troy yes that's my
favorite it's true this is like people
started to forget about the K ID
Oh unlistenable sorry it does hold up by
the way that's not that's not a brag
these right have been being awful and
you can stand still yeah you can [ __ ]
just get drunk and stay still bro he
drinks alcohol he's cool you like cocky
because you have it on the heavier dick
[Laughter]
that's a great point
Troy so jealous yeah of course Troy's
salty this has a lot of hits
what 3.9 million views that but that's
not good enough it's pretty good the
songs been out [ __ ] 15 years
what song tonight yeah I like that song
actually what I like I like it too
there was a song parody of it there's
one of my favorite things ever where the
guy was doing Kryptonite but it was
about Christopher Reeve and his accident
that's not a parody saw and it's one of
my [ __ ] favorite things anyone's ever
done I like you so that's not bad dude
this song sucks oh I think this song is
kind of cool is three doors down stacks
loser sucks yeah yeah three doors down
definitely sucks they're definitely on
the maroon 5 list of bands that suck
it's a bummer when you see how seriously
they take them cuz you're like you hope
they'd have more fun with this and I
don't know what this old man is doing
here yeah they're not having fun with it
they're trying to send a message ah
sucks but that's the problem with being
a rock stars like you think you have to
be this like cool the not everyone's
gonna be cool right sometimes you got to
embrace that you're not cool and that
makes you cool right be yourself don't
try to be a cool rocks I like this so
you guys are crazy
no I agree with you I enjoy the song I
just I like them less after seeing the
video it's a good song Troy that's fine
pretty good again if it comes on in a
restaurant or something you're not like
you're like okay probably tapping your
foot a little bit I think this is good
turn on the old iPod yeah yeah listen to
it as you drop the kids off at school
open the minivan yeah pick up the kids
at soccer practice listen to this yeah
why not
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app